Let's now consider two
dimensional motion,
and let's try to
analyze how to describe
the change in velocity.
So again, let's choose
a coordinate system.
We have an origin plus y plus x.
And let's draw the
trajectory of our object.
And now let's draw the object
at two different times.
So for instance, if I call
this the location at time t1,
and a little bit
later here, this
is the location of
the object at time t2.
We'll call our unit
vectors i hat and j hat.
We know that the
direction of the velocity
is tangent to this curve.
So if we draw v at time
t1-- and over here,
notice the direction has
changed v at time t2.
And what we'd like to do now
is describe, just as before,
that our acceleration a of t is
the derivative of the velocity
as a function of time.
What that means is the
limit as delta t goes
to 0 of delta v over delta t.
Now, it's much harder
to visualize the delta v
in this drawing.
And partly, the reason for
that is these velocity vectors
are located at two
different points.
And right now, the
backs of these vectors
have different places in space.
But remember that delta v
is just v, in this case,
at time t2 minus v at time t1.
And our principle for
subtracting two vectors
at different
locations in space is
to draw the vectors where we put
the tails at the same location.
So here's a tail at this vector.
We're just going to translate
that vector in space.
That is still v at time t1.
These vectors are equal.
They have the same length, and
they have the same direction.
And so delta v is
just the vector
that connects here to there.
That's what we mean by delta v.
And so you can see in
this particular case
that it's not obvious from
looking at the orbit what
the delta v is.
So what we need to do is
just trust our calculus.
And so when we write the
velocity as dx dt i hat plus dy
dy j hat, and we're now treating
each direction independently.
We call this vx i
hat plus vy j hat.
So that's our velocity vector.
Then our acceleration is just
the derivative of the velocity.
We take each
direction separately,
so we have dv x dt i
hat plus dv y dt j hat.
Now, again, notice
that velocity v of x
is already the first
derivative of the position
of the exponent function.
So what we really have here
is the second derivative
of the position
function in the i hat
direction and the second
derivative of the component
function in the y direction.
And that is what we call the
instantaneous acceleration.
Now, again, this is
sometimes awkward to draw,
but you always must remember
that this x component
of the acceleration
by definition
is the second derivative
of the component function
or the first derivative
of the component
function for the velocity.
And likewise, the y component
of the acceleration ay
is the second derivative
of the component
function for position.
And that's also
equal, by definition,
to the first derivative of
the component of the velocity
vector.
And that's how we
describe the acceleration.
As before, we can talk about
the magnitude of a vector.
And the magnitude of a
we'll just write as a.
It's the components squared,
added together, taken
square root.
And that's our magnitude.
And so now we've described all
of our kinematic quantities
in two dimensions--
the position,
the velocity as the
derivative of the position,
and the acceleration as the
derivative of the velocity
where each direction is
treated independently.